von alex & co bis hin zur smart home
anwendung in den eigenen vier wänden die
wachsende digitalisierung bringt viele
vorteile
macht uns aber auch angreifbar wie groß
ist die bedrohung sven herbig ist
experte für sicherheitspolitik arbeitet
für die stiftung neue verantwortung und
sagt dazu cyberangriffe generell sind
sehr gefährlich sie können dazu führen
dass unternehmen bankrott gehen können
aber auch dazu führen dass sie ein
großer ihrer daten verlieren sie als
privatperson zum beispiel die sie nicht
wieder bringen können und von daher sind
cyberangriffe generell erst mal ein
großes gefährdungsrisiko für die
bundesrepublik deutschland
so gab es laut bka 2018 rund 87.000
fälle von cyberkriminalität ein anstieg
um 1,3 prozent schaden 60 millionen euro
er sogar noch mehr meist machen wir es
den hackern leicht normalerweise ist es
so dass hacker versuchen mit den
einfachsten mitteln in ihre systeme
einzudringen das heißt sie schicken
ihren zum beispiel eine e mail mit einem
manipulierten link oder manipulierten
anhang hoffen dass sie darauf klicken
und sich so eine schadsoftware einfangen
vor knapp einem jahr war der bundestag
das ziel von hacker-angriffen
veröffentlicht wurden persönliche daten
von politikern immer wieder auch im
visier kritische infrastruktur wie dies
oft wird von krankenhäusern die christen
infrastruktur zum beispiel oder auch die
kleinen und mittleren unternehmen haben
eine besonders hohe gefährdungslage
gleichzeitig sind hier oft nicht
ausreichend finanzielle oder personelle
ressourcen vorhanden um diese systeme zu
schützen doch es gibt auch erfolge
das bka konnte mit internationalen
partnern verkaufsplattformen im darknet
schließen bei wall street market gab es
unter anderem drogen und falschgeld zu
kaufen die herausforderung für die
ermittler passendes personal zu finden
die fachkräfte situation in deutschland
im bereich it sicherheit sehr angespannt
und wenn wir dann noch einen schritt
weitergehen und sicherheitsfachkräfte in
den behörden angucken ist die situation
sehr problematisch langfristig geht
deutschland hier sehr sinnvoll vor es
gibt neue studiengänge
das bka will jedenfalls in den nächsten
jahren aufrüsten mit mehr personal und
geld für die bekämpfung der
cyberkriminalität